bonjour à tous aujourd'hui on va parler
du futur samsung s 9 m/s news
les femmes sous jacente est cette année
le suit et suit plus et le note 8 3
smartphones de smartphones est une fable
est si on souhaite qu'ils marchent
plutôt bien qu'ils sont vraiment sympas
mais il ya plein de nouveautés qui vont
arriver pour s'absoudre les temps à
venir à commencer par un tout nouveau
smartphone qui devrait sortir en début
d'année le samsung galaxy s 9 et le
samsung galaxy s 9 + devrait aussi y
avoir une annonce extraordinaire qu'on
attend depuis des années c'est le
samsung galaxy s ou samsung galaxy 10
dès demain il y aura une nouvelle vidéo
pour vous parler de ça et vous allez
voir on n'est pas au bout de nos
surprises pour l'instant on va se
recentrer sur le samsung galaxy s 9 pour
voir un petit peu bien ce qui nous
attend si ce nouveau modèle ce nouveau
flagship va être bien intéressant est ce
que ça va valoir le coup de changer oui
non alors pour l'instant aucune
révélation officielle je vous reste sûre
pour l'instant toutes les informations
qu'on a sont de la rumeur c'est du ragot
c'est du potin c'est les infos qui
circulent sur internet
mais on sait qu'en terme de potins il ya
souvent des informations glanées à
droite à gauche qui sont très
intéressantes et pourquoi c'est
intéressant on en a parlé tous et vous
permet un petit peu de sentir les
tendances de voir ce qui se profile ce
cas souvent des rumeurs qui sont fondés
donc c'est intéressant il est regardé de
les écouter et puis après on fait tri
dans tout ça alors ce s9 va apporter une
différence par rapport aux essuie c'est
un reproche qui a été énormément fait
suite à savoir que le capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé à l'arrière
de l'appareil pour déverrouiller trop
près du capteur photo était pas génial
on laissait souvent son doit traîner sur
l'appareil on trouve pas facilement
c'était une vraie galère a priori le
capteur d'empreintes digitales serait
descendu un peu plus bas et forcément en
aura une position peu plus ergonomique
au lieu d'aller le chercher sur le on
descendra ou glissera et on va le
retrouver au milieu et ça y'a pas à dire
c'est vraiment beaucoup plus intelligent
ya une rumeur qui faisait état un temps
d'avoir un scanner d'empreintes
digitales positionné sous l'écran alors
pour l'instant c'est toujours pas le cas
cette rumeur on avait déjà retrouvé
également sur ce qui devait être le
futur iphone l'iphone 8 l'iphone disent
ça n'a pas eu lieu pour l'instant
samsung ne sort pas on sait pas si c'est
parce que la technologie n'est pas
encore au point
tout simplement parce qu'il ya peut-être
une technologie un peu sous le coude
on va retrouver un déverrouillage à la
reconnaissance faciale qu'on l'a déjà
sur le galaxy s uite suit plus et le
début
viage avec le capteur d'empreintes
digitales à l'arrière à smartphone qui
devrait garder le même écran que celui
qu'on trouve sur le et suit ensuite plus
à savoir alain cran infiniti display qhd
plus avec un ratio 18/9 l'écran a priori
ne devrait pas changer il faut dire que
l'écran infiniti du samsung galaxy et
suite et ensuite lui sont les meilleurs
écrans actuellement sur le marché
alors à voir avec le lgv 30 et avec
l'iphone 10 la comparaison
vraiment je dirai au point de détail
près mais en tout cas ce qui est sûr
c'est que l'écran du samsung galaxy s
suit est vraiment extraordinaire et on
se retrouve exactement la même qualité
dans le x 9,9 plus côté processeur on
devrait trouver un qualcomm snapdragon
845 cadencé à 1,78 gigahertz un
processeur encore plus petit gravé en 7
nanomètres alors qu'est ce que ça
apporte d'avoir un processeur gravé ans
est un ado m tout simplement un
processeur niña tu risée un processeur
qui prend encore moins de place mais il
faut savoir que ce fameux qualcomm 845
serait 30% plus puissant que la
génération précédente
samsung serait le premier à utiliser le
snapdragon 845 sur un de ses modèles lg
avec son lg g7 qui sortira l'année
prochaine
arrivera juste après donc au final andré
abord un samsung galaxy s 9 beaucoup
plus puissants que les le samsung galaxy
et suite
alors il ya une rumeur qui faisait état
d'un probable processeur exynos 9810
pour l'instant ça serait a priori le sla
dragon 845 qui serait préférée il y
aurait même un contrat à priori pour
toujours des petites pincettes quand je
dis ça qui serait signé avec qualcomm un
smartphone qui devrait avoir 4 gigas de
mémoire et 64 gigaoctets de stockage ça
pour le produit initial on sait très
bien que samsung préfère regarder des
produits un peu plus sûr booster en
mémoire pour la gamme note
est-ce qu'on va arriver aussi giga de
ram et aux 8 gigas de ram ça pour
l'instant on n'en sait rien le stockage
64 giga c'est minimum 128 pourquoi pas
256 512 ça c'est vraiment de
l'hypothétique côté os on va retrouver
une surcouche expérience lui qui va
tourner sur un android 8.0 oreo un
smartphone qui devrait avoir une
certification ip68
d'un point de vue technique ce convoi
par rapport aux éléments qu'on a
aujourd'hui c'est qu'en réalité le s9
sera une évolution de l'est suite il
corrige certains regrets qu'on avait sur
le x8
en gros le s9 surround suite ce que le
fctt os 6 c'est à dire un modèle un peu
plus performant mais qui sera pas
forcément une grande révolution
en gros c'est une évolution mais pas une
révolution il faut croire que samsung a
pris le pli d'apple c'est à dire sortir
un vrai modèle qui tranche avec le reste
tous les deux ans et vous sortent un
modèle qui cartonne une vraie évolution
c'est d'ailleurs ce qu'a été le galaxy
et suit ensuite un modèle qui corrige
qui s'améliore et ensuite un autre
modèle qui cartonne pourquoi qu'est ce
qu'on peut voir dans cette stratégie
bah tout simplement un truc un petit peu
malin c'est à dire que si vous êtes un
vrai fan de samsung vous vous dites
barèges de changer mon 500e y avoir le
dernier modèle le modèle qui cartonne
tous les ans ça commence à faire un
petit peu cher c'est des modèles qui
s'approche tout doucement des 1000 euros
donc mais tous les ans 850 euros 1000
euros dans un nouveau smartphone bon ça
commence à faire cher l'idée de changer
tous les ans est hyper intelligent
vous avez une base elles changent tous
les deux ans parce que tous les ans
c'est beaucoup trop rapprochés par
contre tous les gens qui au milieu ben
non pas forcément marques précises sont
pas forcément fan d'apple samsung et lg
weiwei ou compagnie est bien à ce moment
là vous pouvez les capter sur des
modèles qui sont un peu plus boosté et
vous êtes toujours au rendez vous vous
faites par les deux bouts avec un modèle
de l'actualité et puis vous innovez tous
les deux ans samsung devrait bousculer
son calendrier cette année au lieu de
sortir son nouveau modèle au mois de
mars comme il l'a fait l'année dernière
sur la suite il devrait le présenter en
avant première aux crs au mois de
janvier à las vegas alors pourquoi tout
simplement parce qu'il devrait y avoir
cette année une annonce majeure au mois
de mars
il est sorti à l'ès 9 plus tôt et super
intelligente aujourd'hui tout le monde
parle de l'iphone 10 l'iphone 10 va
occuper le terrain jusqu'à fin d'année
voire début d'année prochaine
l'idée de samsung est très maline arrivé
à partir de janvier au cs tout le monde
va parler du nouveau samsung galaxy s 9
occuper le terrain jusqu'au mois de mars
où là on va parler du galaxy 10 ensuite
on va laisser descendre doucement la
pression jusqu'au mois de juin pour
attaquer en septembre avec le note 9 ce
qui fait que ça ne se jouera vraiment
occupé le terrain de janvier 2018
jusqu'à septembre voire octobre 2018
stratégie gagnante pour vendre des
produits pour faire parler de soi il rit
les prototypes du s9 sont sortis en
octobre et la fabrication commencerait
la lah directement au mois de décembre
autre cheval de bataille pour samsung
l'intelligence artificielle sam sont
aujourd'hui mais apple lg au nord why
your way et tous les autres grands
fabricants vont vraiment se positionner
petit à petit dans l'intelligence
artificielle pourquoi simplement pour
optimiser les produits dans un premier
temps et puis ensuite avoir des
nouvelles évolutions y avoir un vrai
smartphone intelligent dans un éco
système intelligent avec de
l'intelligence artificielle dans son
smartphone
on pourra gagner en autonomie en
sécurité avoir de meilleures photos de
meilleure vidéo un appareil qui comprend
vos besoins qui comprend votre vie et
qui répondent encore mieux à vos besoins
toute la stratégie des grandes firmes
comme samsung comme apple nous
développer l'intelligence artificielle
c'est un enjeu majeur de mal business à
se faire avec une vraie connaissance de
l'utilisateur si votre marque de
smartphone vous comprend réellement sais
qui vous êtes ce que vous aimez tel
produit vous consommez de quelle manière
vous vivez il pourra vous proposer les
produits les plus adaptés
alors ça peut être flippant je suis
d'accord il faut faire attention
il faut sécuriser ses données on est
d'accord ça facilite la vie mais il faut
quand même être prudent et ça que c'est
quand même une avancée intéressante si
ça peut nous aider
d'une certaine manière why not voilà ce
qu'on peut dire un petit peu aujourd'hui
sur ce futur samsung galaxy s 9 samsung
galaxy s 9 plus je vous dis restez
connectés parce que dès demain matin on
va parler du samsung galaxy de samsung
galaxy x et sachez que ce smartphone va
être une vraie révolution
il va ouvrir la porte à une nouvelle ère
pour la téléphonie merci d'avoir regardé
cette vidéo
mettez-moi tous vos commentaires
dites-moi est-ce que vous avez samsung
est ce que vous avez le n8 est ce qui
vous a déçu mais ce que le capteur
d'empreintes digitales place un peu trop
et bien c'est une galère est-ce que vous
jouez ce que vous sentez de la latence
va vous marquez tout ça on en discute
dites moi ce que vous attendez sur le
samsung galaxy s 9 et s9 plus
mettez moi un jour y poussent
abonnez-vous à la chaîne parce qu aura
toujours toujours est toujours plus de
contenu pour parler du high tech quant à
moi je vous dis à bientôt portez vous
bien
oui ça ciao